people bring up like you have to have
everything planned out before in order
for a show to work and you look at
Breaking Bad which Vince Gilligan admits
like we didn't know what the gun was for
we didn't know what this was for but
also Breaking Bad is made in this era of
10 13 episode seasons not only did you
guys have to come up with that story
you're doing it on network television
where every single episode as you said
was do or die you could get cancelled
but you're doing 24 25 episodes of
season which for some shows now is like
three seasons worth of story that's like
the entire duration of the left overs we
might hate episodes of that so that's
just three more than season 1 of lost
yeah would and so that's why and that's
why I think the show works really well
but that's why I think it's so
fascinating you guys were one of the
first shows if not the first show to
negotiate that end point to go to ABC
and say like we need to end and we need
we need to know where the end is and we
need to know we need a shorter amount of
episodes per season and I was curious
from your perspective I think the deal
was you got three additional seasons was
three was that as the the amount that
you wanted or did you guys want to end
it sooner I know all this happened
during season three I'm not trying to be
diplomatic I'm trying to give you the
the most accurate answer the way that I
remember it which is the comment that
the conversations about wanting the show
to end began as early as the pilot you
know like one of the notes that we were
just getting back from ABC was you know
when are you gonna resolve these
mysteries and once you resolve these
mysteries why are people gonna keep
watching the show and level one of that
was well we're gonna be introducing new
mysteries as we go
so hopefully for every one that we
answer we've left a new compelling
mystery set up a new compelling mystery
and if we get that balance right people
it's they're not gonna stack up I think
that we can both agree that we did not
get that balance right so but it's but
but it's sort of like as you go so if
you look at Twin Peaks for example which
is my favorite show of all time and and
arguably the second season is not that
great
but they they by time they revealed who
killed Laura Palmer
there wasn't they hadn't laid the seed
on any other compelling mysteries to
keep keep people engaged in the show
even though I was still much more
interested in the Black Lodge and all
the crazy [ __ ] that was happening around
Laura Palmer's murder but for people who
were just like watching the show to have
that question answered there was really
nothing in its wake so lost was like
okay like what's in the hatch what's up
with the monster you know who's the
original Sawyer how did lock it in the
wheelchair you know like what is the
nature of the island is it why why does
it appear to be moving who are the
others like so it there were all these
compelling mysteries and so we were
saying we want to we want to have this
stuff answered by the end of season one
and this stuff answered by the end of
season two and that and then the show
basically ends after about three years
that was the initial pitch and they were
not even hearing it they it they looked
at particularly me and Carlton came on
about midway through season one and he
joined the chorus of me but they were
just like do you understand how hard it
is to make a show that people want to
watch and you got and people liked the
show so why would we end it you don't do
that like you don't end shows that
people are watching and so we got all
the way to the end of season two and
then tried to formalize the conversation
again and that at that point it was
formal because Carlton and I both had
two year deals that ended after season
two and so we were now negotiating for
the future of the show and they thought
that they were in a monetary negotiation
where it was like we were trying to get
more money and all we were trying to get
was for them to agree to end the show
and so neither side blinked and so we
agreed to sign a one-year extension
Carlton and I with the understanding
that we'd be leaving at the end of the
third season and someone else would be
running the show and right at that same
time alias it ended so lost absorbed a
number of the fantastic alias writers
including
to goddard it would already written some
episodes of loss and second season Jeff
Pinkner who's incredible was going to
kind of be the heir apparent for season
three but all this time whenever when
ABC would be like why do you want to end
the show we were like these flashbacks
are finite you know you can do like
three flashbacks of Jack getting drunk
and like being self-destructive or
Charlie relapsing or Kate running away
from the marshal that is chasing her but
ultimately that stuff the first one
feels like an origin story because
you're learning about that person for
the very first time but all the all the
other ones feel like you're just kind of
treading water so we're gonna have to
switch gears at it we can introduce new
characters who have new flashback
stories but people are invested in the
old ones so we're seeing down we're
seeing about eight chess moves ahead and
it ain't gonna end pretty and they just
didn't agree with us the beginning of
season three happens those six episodes
air because ABC decides that they're
going to split the season into two parts
they'll air six episodes basically like
from October to December and then
they'll resume again with Episode seven
through 21 or whatever it was in the
spring because the reruns weren't
working and there was a lot of confusion
as to when the show was on and when the
show was off after those six episodes
aired of season three they finally
understood and we were not phoning it in
or trying to spike the show we always
did our best but it became clear that we
were working so hard to keep the
characters on the island like and it was
starting to be immensely frustrating and
the flashbacks weren't good anymore and
like other than the addition of Michael
Emerson as a regular and an Ian Cusick
as a regular and and auto wale and and
Michelle Rodriguez and Cynthia Watrous
the tale set the tail section some of
that stuff was working but all the other
stuff wasn't and then they finally came
to the table and we had a real
conversation about like okay so
they were like we have agreed to let you
end the show and I was like I can't
believe I'm hearing these words because
every not only them but my ate my own
agents were saying this is never gonna
happen
and I was like I just said to stephen
fierson thank you like thank you this is
what's best for the show and he was like
and then he said we were thinking like
ten seasons you can end it after ten
seasons and mind you we're halfway
through season three so I'm like first
off how do you how do you think we're
even gonna get to ten and that and
that's really the same as saying we're
not gonna let you in the show because
how many drama series even get to ten
seas it's like and I was like I was
thinking more like four and that and not
because I was in a negotiation but
because we had actually already worked
out the oceanic six story to some degree
where we knew that a number of
characters were gonna get off the island
they were gonna have a very miserable
time when they were off the island and
then they were gonna come back for the
big finale you know and we we felt like
we could kind of do that and starting in
the back half of season three and then
have one more season season four which
would have been a full season of
television 20-some odd episodes to do it
all and they were like how about nine
okay so the agreement was we landed on
six with less episodes to give us more
time in between seasons to sort of plan
things out and and then of course the
fourth season was cut short by the
strike by the writer strike but
everything else kind of went relatively
according to design not to say that
everything that we did worked but like
we had a plan and then we executed that
plan